it is not an unusual site in
Iran a large conference attended only by
men after all women are to be hidden
from public view kept
uneducated silent
powerless it is Within These strict
confines that a young woman eyes bright
with possibility for a more just and
Equitable World bravely steps into this
Gathering of men with her veil
removed her face is
uncovered an act considered
Blasphemous just the presence of this
woman alone sends shock waves through
the
crowd she declares that the time has
come to break away from Antiquated
traditions and step into a new era era
of human
consciousness in which every person is
free to choose their own
path soon after she is
imprisoned charged with spreading
corruption on Earth and sentenced to
death this woman was
tahara a poet a Mystic a champion for
human
rights now this story may sound like a
recent headline from Iran but it
actually took place nearly 200 years ago
in
1848 when I look at my birthplace of
Iran today I have to ask what's changed
have we made any
progress I see taha's fate being
replayed in the lives of other
courageous women
who at this very moment are choosing
nonviolent means such as speaking out
and removing their hijabs to Proclaim
their
freedoms and tragically just like
tahar their lives and the rights they
are defending are being Stamped Out and
suffocated it's easy to feel
hopeless it's easy to feel
defeated
yet within their stories and within hers
I do see
progress I see powerful lessons about
what it means to believe so deeply in
the transformation of
society that we dedicate Our Lives to
laying down the building blocks of a
better
world a world we may not even live to
see taha's life is an example of being
undeterred by our limitations and our
constraints in an arranged marriage
since the age of
14 and with three children tahara still
used whatever tools she had within her
means her words her actions her poetry
to encourage all of those around her to
abandon the suffocating scripts that
they had inherited for their
lives and to independent ly investigate
the truth for
themselves she was met with hostile
opposition abuse and
imprisonment yet Taha was unflinching in
her
efforts fixing her eyes on a horizon
line of justice and freedom for
all through taha's actions we understand
the power that sacrifice has and a
Awakening a collective
Consciousness though much of her writing
and her poetry was destroyed after her
death her Legacy could not be
extinguished so many hearts were
transformed by the teachings that she
spread and the seeds of possibility that
she planted for equality and freedom are
now bursting through the soil of Iran as
evidenced in these Brave youthful female
Le protests that are erupted following
the tragic death of Masa xina amini the
22-year-old kurish shiranian woman who
died in police custody after being
arrested for improperly wearing her
hijab now today when I hear that
rallying cry woman life
freedom I can't help but hear T's last
words before she was executed
taken in the middle of the night and
strangled with her own
scarf she
said you can kill me as soon as you like
but you cannot stop the emancipation of
women you can kill me as soon as you
like but you cannot stop the
emancipation of
women taha's Legacy invites each of us
to consider consider what is fueling our
own
activism her words and actions though
radical and upending were not born out
of bitterness or hatred or fueled by
self-interest it was T's deep love for
Humanity that propelled her
forward and therein lies our
challenge can we stand up against
oppression and
Injustice while deeply rooting our
thoughts our words our actions in
compassion and
love taha's life teaches us that we must
act with urgency and conviction while
recognizing that we may not live to see
the fruits of our
efforts we cannot expect immediate
gratification in our pursuit of Justice
because the transformation of society is
a multi-generational
Endeavor so what can we
do we can take to heart taha's
trailblazing example and in every moment
we too can bravely choose to do the next
right
thing knowing that we are planting seeds
that will grow into trees under whose
branches future Generations will find
Justice and peace
I want to end with a poem of tahz
translated from its original language of
farsy not only because it feels like it
could have been written today in light
of all the conflicts we are witnessing
with broken hearts all around the world
but also because she offers us a clear
and poignant call to action at a time
where we might be asking ourselves what
we want our Legacy to
be
let Waring ways be banished from the
world let Justice everywhere its carpet
throw May friendship reconcile ancient
hatreds may love grow from the seed of
love we
sow thank
you